I don't know why I do that anyway
welcome back to some more lastolite this
will definitely be the last episode I
knew tell it I don't just gotta win how
to do that and now we power the
generator we will put these little
sticks this one says three and that it
goes what that one goes there what my
unit work stop moving fine I'll put one
first
Jace's yeah alright JD has pit strikes I
got and we did a breast I'm proud of you
didn't you really do anything good yet
yeah dude you did a lot of things
I made you sat there with me it's all
time I mean that's pretty impressive I
wouldn't do that
I mean I would I mean this is poor Liz
lever this is really weird
all right Wow yeah
what Oh like and [ __ ] I'm out of here
that is one big-ass generator holy [ __ ]
alright the question is now where the
[ __ ] did we go I can go over hey I hope
it's over here
I really really help but this could be
wrong
we'll see let's go let's go
I know what that was what's iodine
uh-huh nice all right I gotta keep
playing now if you don't mind let's go
on with your stories I'm just kidding I
love your stories now you're the best
uh-huh all right cool
what am I going buck I went in the wrong
alright see you in a second
I didn't even can sniff sweaty alright
now I know I'm really terrible I'm sorry
hey are you angry whoa
why does it keep doing that it's [ __ ]
freaks me out that is a huge spider win
here we got brass I think I know where
to go it's been a while man it's been a
while a lot of loading screens don't you
like it
it's so we can talk you know between our
little rendezvous it's don't you like it
No
right have we got whoa that is a big
agile kill you
whoa whoa this is awesome hello what is
what in the hell are they are feeding us
nightmares with that thing this is
actually kind of [ __ ] creepy
I don't know why I'm so creeped out by
this more puzzles [ __ ] yeah
all right whatever have over here
goddamnit
that door here
hello okay I'm officially a little
[ __ ] creeped out by this I don't know
why I'll tell you why cause it came to
this ad I'm sorry what's going on here
people are working what's up its share
what is up for this place
what giant TVs how do I open that door
is there a button
I don't know
this is epic all what should I do
I don't know it's not even Euler
anything let's check out these power
boxes maybe most likely I know but
whatever you never know
great great
[Music]
god damnit I'm an idiot kids this is
just like the first game you're an idiot
these are obviously linked together I'm
such an idiot
look at that hotshot what
whoa
all right next one Oh Lady Gaga put come
on man come on and hit it
oh hell did it did it okay I'll bye bye
whoa whoa
whoa holy shet I'm running hi dad
jump
oh shut Conrad
strutting back about jumping like a
bunny grunting like a bunny jumping like
a [ __ ] come on
right right I'm drowning Jesus Christ
I mean Rob
and stones in the way
dad
[ __ ] all right
knock-knock
okay No
well they just
oh man yeah
that I'm up today
you've got heads
Oh check okay
almost after this [ __ ] tonight
my airs on exploding data that's how I
roll I'm pretty good right
[Music]
well now they were decent decent can we
agree on decent alright yeah we got what
much - whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa shells
your chance but it's going out
am i on drugs I think I'm on drugs well
that is nice that is not safe open
please why they siren I need to get the
hell out of here
what in the hell
am I supposed to go in are they shooting
what is going on what am i go away all
right here we go breasts on an air i
felt did all this chaos come from their
power I guess so
holy [ __ ]
I guess we shouldn't touch that little
thing should be but we had to escape
holy [ __ ] I guess I'll just follow these
lights unless we made it out of the
castle he did David Ward me for this god
damn it David I disappointed you
Wow alrighty then why the [ __ ] am I
supposed to go oh ok over there there's
something going on over there lucky
lucky lucky lucky well well well well
well
all this shooting and bombardment the
Power Core releases first did I create a
world war from the power cord world war
from a power co I don't even know how to
score wind up a cigar alright have a gun
what is this oh no no I'm sorry I didn't
mean to crash [ __ ] I closed my eyes as
they raped me I said nothing
did nothing and the tides stopped moving
and suddenly I realized I never was a
good idea Joe below that unknown power
cord without what consequences were I
created chaos and death to those poor
people I deserve to die for this
all right don't be so hard on yourself
do you hear me grunts ready Kanna me
you're really ranked him good
here's rape charge on funny look I'm
sorry I did don't quite city ready cool
custom sorry really cool I really
appreciate it because I had a good
length and it was really enjoyable all
the way through so I hope you bros
enjoyed this well I'm gonna start a new
cousin story right right after this one
actually but great job and see legend
like and favorite if you enjoyed its
Craddock oh right today and I'll see you
next time